welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims or should i
say the four muslims because we got one
of our og guests brother gabriel salaam
alaikum bro
quick little thing for anyone that made
it this far if you don't know who
brother gabriel armani is he's one of
the biggest forces right now in the
youtube dawah so head over to his
channel links in the description gabriel
romani hit subscribe like and share his
content and one last thing that i wanted
to say for those of you that don't know
we probably filmed like 20 30 40 videos
with you thus far i don't know the exact
number but what i do know i was speaking
to rami about this before is we're
thinking of uh launching merch you know
very soon insha'allah in the next few
weeks or months um
what i want to do is we're going to do a
little bit of a giveaway so find us on
instagram the three muslims one word
follow us
the first dm that we get for the correct
number
of videos that we have filmed with
gabriel
we'll get a free hoodie insha allah
all right so do i get a free hoodie free
hoodie bro i don't know the numbers
don't get one i don't get one somewhere
around 30 25 30 but inshallah
brought you back
go be back baby all right so brother
gabriel
let's break the ice very lightly all
right
people have been painting
muslim prophets muslim men
as
however they want to paint it today
subhanallah you got pink islam you got a
lot of movements you know saying we turn
the other cheek and whatnot but people
don't understand that
masculinity is one of the forefronts of
muslim men
the believing men
right so why don't you start us off a
little bit about you know where this
even comes from is this something that
muslim men just have it by birth is it
because it's from allah allah wants us
to be that way
it's a great topic
it's a great topic especially given the
current
geopolitical situation in the world
been traveling a little bit in the past
few months and
i have to say that it is
indeed i'm not i've known this but it is
indeed a global village
we're living in a global village
yes there is a slight difference between
the east and the west to an extent
but that difference that gap is slowly
slowly
getting smaller and smaller
and it is due to the fact that
social media
the
propaganda that's bleeding into the
muslim ummah
is
i can't even say bleed is like the
floodgates have opened
it is really really
coming to
to our countries to the muslim countries
it's it's without a doubt not traveling
i mean i know that
but you know sometimes you need to be
reminded of these things and you need to
see them so you can understand how real
these issues are
so i've traveled to quite a few
countries in the last two months
and the same you know i meet with
community leaders community members
people on the
ground doing the ground work
and they're saying the same thing bro
the same thing
we are having some major issues
as you said there's pink islam there's
all kinds of forget about
forget about the non-muslims right now
we're talking about muslims
we're talking about
the problems that we have in our
backyard
we're talking about what's happening
back home in our own
environment
our own places
and i think
if we don't clean up early enough
there's going to be a time close enough
time
where we won't be able to recognize
ourselves
mark my words
we will not be able to recognize
ourselves anymore and we're getting
close to that right now
if you look around at what's happening
we are getting quite close to that
alhamdulillah
that
as allah has promised that there will
always be a
group there will be fighting
uh
the halal fighting you know pushing
forward
and i'm trying to be careful here sorry
man with the terms i know you told me
but there is there's always going to be
a group of people who is going to push
back
okay he's going to push back and i pray
and i ask allah with all my faults and
all my
mistakes and all of us that we are part
of that group inshallah i pray that what
we are doing here
with our podcast
is
yeah i've seen some comments people
thinking we're just looking for
for
you know numbers or whatever
but i ask allah to make it sincere that
we will be amongst those
who will push back
through our discussions
through our
interactions
from the messages that we're receiving i
do believe that it is making a
difference
it's a small difference
but it is significant
it is significant
it's a small difference but it's
significant
yeah
so
having said that i think this topic
i was talking to
to
to my wife the other day
and i was telling we just there was a
discussion about
certain issues and i said look
people need to understand
that
we men men as rijal
we are the first ones to be responsible
for this ummah and it's not because i
want to you know we oh
the three muslims and
romario i mean romania is
as
they're trying to to to to be all
masculine and all that alpha it's not
that is that allah subhana tala has
has charged us with this responsibility
there's no there's no option
this
this a man has been put on us we've
accepted this
and we're first responsible so what i
was telling my wife i said
people watch our videos and they think
we're bashing women we're not bashing
women
we are trying to explain to women what
their fault is
actually we are targeting men first and
foremost
because we are the ones to be blamed
first and foremost
it is what it is right if you lose a
football game
you're not going to
to blame the other team oh why you're so
good no it's like man why didn't i train
enough why didn't i take care
and put the effort
and push harder to make sure that the
other team doesn't beat me
so we're in a time and situation right
now where we're getting smashed left and
right
by so many different groups
yes they have their fault
they have their fault of course not that
no one's absolved the default
but first and foremost first priority
comes to us when we accept them we
realize that
and people then maybe we can start
working
people again they don't understand it's
like you know when a father catches his
son smoking
right
and his son will say well i saw you
smoke it's your fault dad
you you gave me that example
now does that make the son is he
absolved of the fault no he made a
choice though
he himself chose to smoke
but the huge responsibility of terbia
and raising and setting up an example is
on the father no doubt about it
right both are at fault and this is it
we men are saying okay women women women
of course they have the big fault and
that's what we're fighting it because
it's a huge front
however
first and foremost we need to
set ourselves straight and that's what
we're trying to do and people don't get
it you know like sometimes tired you
know you gotta explain to people man
no i don't hate women no we don't hate
women no we're not gonna talk about
masculine prophets today because we hate
women
you know that's not what we're talking
about it's about because we're trying to
fix
guys we're trying to get guys to man up
and
none of us can say that yeah i'm there
man 100 i'm the man
we're all on a journey i don't claim
that i'm the man
i'm on a journey i'm i'm at least on the
journey i'm claiming that i'm on the
journey
i don't think i've ever claimed i'm the
man man or the three muslims are the man
man we got it all locked down come you
know follow us we're saying follow allah
and his messenger
we remind you with allah and his
messenger we remind with the real men
muhammad sallallahu alaihi sallam
with the real
which were the envy
of allah subhanahu ta'ala
this is who remind you that's what we're
called to
we don't call you to
ourselves we call you to musa
who's mentioned 136 times in the quran
we call it ibrahim alaihissalam was
mentioned 69 times in the quran we call
it
mentioned 43 times in the quran we we're
calling you to luth
27 times yusuf al-islam 27 times
25 times adam alaihi salam 25 times
harun 20 times sulaiman 17 times
ishaq 17 times dawud 16 times and so on
and so forth
and allah says in surah in verse 7 um
we did not
send
before you oh muhammad saw except men
okay allah says
except
here it's
clear there's been there's been a small
slight difference of opinion among some
of the scholars
who said for example like okay but the
angel spoke to maryam alaysalam so maybe
that's actually
um the
yani the word wahi and
yani what what does it mean to inspire
the olive responded back allah talks in
surah nahal
uh that he inspired the be the b is not
a prophet
right so actually this verse is very
clear because there's a
there's an exception here he says
we did not send any prophets
any before you
except
men were sent so why
why is that is it because we are
sexist or because allah hates women or
something like no it's because it is a
fact that's just the way it is that's
what allah decided
that's what allah decided to
put this huge responsibility on us
and we've accepted it it is what it is
no
um so two things i want to say one you
you mentioned that we have the
responsibility it's not about being
power hungry it's about responsibility
we got to pray 30 days out of the month
unlike women right we got to go to jama
it's obligatory for us right
and there's a lot of things that we're
going to be held accountable for by
allah
you know i don't care what i think what
you think what someone else thinks
what should matter first and foremost is
how allah holds us accountable right so
there's a huge amount of responsibility
that's one and my last point is when you
were talking about the the father who's
a smoker and doesn't absolve the
responsibility reminds me of a story
where there was uh there was a
i think it was uh someone's dad right he
was an alcoholic and he had two sons
right
one of them became an alcoholic addict
you know ended up on the streets
homeless
the second son he was very successful he
didn't drink never drank
and he was like a multi-millionaire you
know very successful high integrity and
everything
both of them were asked the same
question
why did you end up the way you are right
and both of them responded with the
exact same answer because my dad was an
alcoholic
subhanallah
subhanallah
no doubt no doubt
mashallah
ramyan what's on your mind
bro
what are you drinking bro coffee yeah
man coffee at all later 7pm at night
[Laughter]
omar writes unfortunately many muslims
are compromising allah
with the west for change to live the
same way of non-muslim culture yeah yeah
100 it's very unfortunate it is very
very unfortunate because this is
something that happened
during like the renaissance period when
europe began expanding and getting
better
unfortunately the muslims even at that
time they looked to the west and saw
them as some kind of enlightened
thinkers enlightened people and
subhanallah they exchanged one man-made
ideology for another and
uh this is the repercussions of it first
it was the church and they felt the
repercussions of the church and them
just making things up and now it's
liberalism secularism capitalism we're
feeling the repercussions of that
you know men wanting to be women when we
want to be men are thinking that they
are and all this confusion bro all the
people are just confused 100 so i'm
really glad alhamdulillah
we're here to remind people uh that
starting with ourselves obviously we
have to be men we have to stand up
oh i thought he was really still to be
honest i was literally gonna say bro i
really hope he's like still let me see
yeah yeah i thought he gave her a bro i
was literally hoping you were just like
staying still yeah i think you're
lagging
i was like
he's so hyper focused on what i'm saying
he's like sitting there like frozen
um you know actually a verse in the
quran came up actually i want to ask you
a question when allah
can't mean women or anything like that
no no
no
yeah the word is very specific even
though in the arabic language when you
refer to specific things that are
masculine it can include females okay
like uh insane and so on and whatever
and even one of those was asking
you know that look everything seems to
be in the masculine form
all right so then allah revealed you
know
and so on
yeah but when you talk about rijal
specifically
this is something very very specific to
men specifically men all right so
there's masculine words that include
feminine
okay in the arabic language but the word
is basically men
i want to ask that before i before i
said this point because you reminded me
a verse in the quran or allah he says
when he mentions specifically the men
amongst the believers there are men
who you know basically they're they're
truthful in the side of allah and they
make a promise and they keep it to allah
and others who kind of go back in the
word and so on and so forth and it's
amazing
you know to me that allah specifically
calls out the men that there are some
men that stick to their word
yeah also that ayah has a specific
contents and it's something that only
men are called to do the main
responsibility
and that is the risk you know what we're
talking about here right it's only men
to be called so if you look at the syria
the what they are truthful to the
covenant that allah calls them to this
is the pushback that we were talking
about at the beginning
you know and that's the again main
responsibility in that sense is men
you know is men now
bro i don't know what approach you want
to take whether you want to go through
some of the prophets in order whether
you want to just give you know arbitrary
you know stories from the quran and and
you know different hadith
but the floor is all yours man let
people know what we're about to get into
and guys if you made it this far not
only do you you know smash the like
button but comment down below what you
want to see do you want us to turn this
into like a series in sha allah in the
future where we it's like a mini series
you know we talk about the sahaba
radhillahu we talk about the different
prophets
and and we talk about all the the
examples of masculinity in them do you
want it to be uh more like just one
episode let us know in sha allah
five so let's let's start obviously i
would say
uh first and foremost
we should start with uh the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
you know because we don't know where
we're to get from here
so it will be good to for people to
understand one of the things that i've
recently
was brought to my attention i think
you also
mentioned it right
where people are saying well the prophet
saw sallam gave women rights therefore
he is a
a feminist
or something like that just i mean some
of these ridiculous statements are
thrown out there without understanding
no doubt the prophet saws brought rights
to women from allah subhanahu wa
no doubt about that
especially in the
the
situation
at that time
and how women were treated subhanallah
no doubt and
mind you that
a lot of the
it was quite a long time till the west
caught up with that let's say and then
you know they caught up with giving
women rights and then they
went let's say
um super saturated on that and they just
crashed right obviously you can see
what's happening right now
so
definitely that's true but the processor
was not a feminist the prophet sallam
was a masculine prophet because
of what the responsibility or a man that
was given by allah subhanahu was and
only men could carry that
this is a fact this is a fact if you
look at who built the world
who
had issues and yeah people would say
well there who made conflicts and wars
it was also men right to look in the
negative but it's it's due to these
conflicts and wars that in the end truth
came out at some points and it's also
like truth has been buried
allah talks about the quran that if you
were not checked one per one group of
people with another one more facade
would have happened so allah says that
he checks a group of people with another
one if this would have not happened then
more if i forget about today like it's
still peaceful relative speaking to the
second and first world war
it's still
peaceful relatively speaking to the
expansion of the
british empire for example or the roman
empire or or or
so no doubt
that there we are enjoying some peace
even though there are there's wars
around the world there's never been
peace around the world full peace
as they say that the only time there was
peace around the world was when they
reloaded their weapons
that's the only you know the only short
span of time
but
uh that's why masculinity is important
because it is a
pre-requirement to carry that amana
that that responsibility
women have supported no doubt we're not
saying that women have no role let them
stay in the kitchen that's it there's no
you know no women have supported
supported they played a supportive role
a backup rule no doubt we see the wives
of the prophet sallallahu and we see the
wives of the sahaba we see so many
examples
but they've never claimed the front line
till today
it's never happened the way it's
happening today
and
as one of the posts was saying
it's a funny one
this guy was joking but he said man
women picked the best time to come up
with this
nonsense you know it's been like 5 000
years hunting bears and they're like
okay guys you guys do it dude right now
all of a sudden
ac and the offices highways big
buildings systems are in place made by
men by the way
mostly now they're saying yeah yeah
we're out there
i know people are going to get upset but
this the reality is the reality i'm not
trying to upset women
so as one of the comments said let us
let us define what does masculinity mean
according to the uh quran and sunnah
what is masculinity
we talk about this word a lot
there's
people qualify by saying toxic
masculinity i i don't believe
masculinity can be toxic
i do not believe masculine can be toxic
because by definition masculinity is
positive
by definition masculinity means fitra
mephitra of the men
so it cannot be bad allah could not
create something that is bad
it can be used in a bad sense so yes
some people because they're not real men
they've become toxic
or they become bad
bad men and some women have become bad
women because they are not real women
anymore
so masculinity
is the fitra
of a male
a biological male
all right a duco
that is fine-tuned
by the revelation of allah
let me repeat that
it is the fitra of the
male
gender
that is fine-tuned
directed given meaning
by the wahi or revelation of
this allah i would define masculinity
from the quran and the sunnah that's
what concerns us anyway first and
foremost it's not about muscles it's not
about
this and that those however will be
added values
for example
when king
saul
followed
when he gets appointed
he says that allah has chosen him and he
is strong above you he has this specific
characteristic of strength in body jason
allah has used the word jesus in his
body he's strong in his body
so indeed it is a positive quality but
that's not the only thing that makes a
man there's a bunch of
kids who go to the gym and pump iron and
they look round
but they're not men they're just babies
they're babies with muscles
that's not necessarily what but it is
one of the characteristics if it comes
in as a package
strength and body ability
is one of the characteristics of a man
another one is mental strength
or what the
philosophers calls
you know stoicism or the ability to
control your emotions and have strong
mental strength it's very very important
and we find that
over and over again through the quran
through the ambia
having to deal with so much
with so much pressure
so much so many insults
so much psychological bullying from
their people
yet still be able to carry the message
and to call them yeah call me all my
people
even prophet luther
is dealing with these says my people
what are you doing what's wrong with you
guys come on
and then
and then
to sometimes see
the demise of their own people how
difficult that would have been
the prophet saws to see his loved ones
leaving this world
not in the best way
being rejected that takes a huge amount
of mental strength the person lost all
his children
except for one before his death do you
understand what that means can any one
of us who has children be able to sit
here and say well yeah what are you
walking apart no problem
do you understand what it means to bury
your own child
the mental and still wait a second keep
in mind
because we're on mental strength here
right define masculinity
keep in mind
today how people react when they look
they lose a dog let alone a child
i i know someone who left islam because
their dog died
no joke
because they said why would allah do
this to me he took away my puppy that i
love so much
no joke
okay this lady left islam because
because then their dog died
people start questioning god so imagine
you are
there
they delivering the message of allah
and allah takes your children away
wouldn't you say
wait a second i'm working for you why
why this pain takes your wife away
the most
beloved man do you understand what that
means
and people have the guts to say oh
prophet muhammad is just a man he's just
a man
what do you mean just the man he is
the man
he's the man
you know i'm saying
it's like proper so
mental strength
bodily strength
decision
making
knowledge knowledge seeking not just
having knowledge but constantly seeking
knowledge
self-development no fear or
bravery let's say not no fear because
fear is there
it's part of being a man to be afraid
but still doing what you are scared to
do
that's bravery
in the face of the things that you're
afraid of
to do what you are afraid to do
that's one of the characteristics that
we pick from the nba
to sacrifice sacrifice is a huge one
being able to sacrifice everything
for what you believe in
do you understand that
the purpose that that gives you
imagine ibrahim alayhi salaam he was he
put the knife
i know man we're on livestream sorry man
no i'm not saying bro
as we said
he put the thing to his the thing
to his
anak to his
army terms
the the knife and his throat
and he was about to do it
like do you understand like
man
it's
it's it's just it's too much subhanallah
um project rights turn this into a
serious salon by the way always
interesting to learn alhamdulillah may
allah accept it from us um no real sense
of supercharge zakalaka for your support
your brothers do such important work in
a time of huge not male 1 grant you all
genes of those i mean i mean in you too
except from us 100 lover rights toxic
masculinity with two feminine
pick-me-ups are both ways to shut people
up trust me once you figure out how
feminism was formed they become
speechless alhamdulillah
uh he also writes brother angela i hope
your recovery is going well in sha
allah these are some of the
these are some of the characteristics
that go along with defining masculinity
according to the
to the quran
and the greatest one out of all of them
and i mentioned this before in another
lecture
is iman
is iman
without this there is nothing
without this there is nothing and i
think this is the one that we are
the weakest in
we have to admit that we are
in a time
where iman
and taqwa is
at an all-time low and i'll tell you why
people are claiming to love allah
subhana tal
they say we love god
only god can judge us
oh okay i think she's saying that
because i said uh i called her a he but
i'm sorry
says
we're in a time
and all law time of iman
and taqwa and it's apparent because of
how we behave
so people say we love allah how can you
love allah if you don't love his sharia
you know or people say only god can
judge me but he's already judging you is
giving you a shariah he's giving you a
book which you're denying
all over is being denied so
because people will say how do you know
bro you know as um
said we cannot judge people based on
their intentions
he said we can just judge them based on
their actions
i think the ummah needs to
understand
we need to accept that we are weak
once we accept our situation then we
could do something about it people are
calling it something different people
are
trying to evade
this discussion they're trying to evade
they're trying to say why they'll say
you guys are negative you guys are
always talking about this it's all
just
negative
criticizing
anything anyone dares to say something
to someone you have to be so careful you
have to walk on eggshells
so no one gets upset today
you don't want to accept that
it's a problem
it's a problem
because we're never going to be able
to
change ourselves lest we accept that we
are having problems
we need to have we need to accept that
so when we look at the the nba
when we look at the masculine prophets
it's not that they had no issues
it's not that they had no
they were infallible in delivering the
messages
but when you analyze every single
prophet allah subhana tala rectifies
some of their issues as a lesson for us
look at all the prophets
look at every single
the 25 prophets that are mentioned by
name the quran
there's some rectification and some
lesson for all of us
but also for allah to point out their
humanity
today people are
venerating prophets to the level of
divinity and that's how many religions
have been formed going astray from the
path
allah
god the almighty the creator only really
revealed one way of life
so imagine as a straight line and from
the beginning of time to present day
and any
religion
philosophy
that we see today in this world
of so-called coexistence
is basically a deviation from that path
and with those deviations
go goes the fitra
and everything else to the point where
people cannot recognize they don't know
who they are or what they are anymore
they don't know what they are
what gender they are
even what race they are these days
people are trying everyone's trying to
be a different race today that's a funny
another discussion i had the other day
everyone is trying to be another race
today
to the point that they are using
surgical procedures
used to be just acting and talking in a
certain way now it is way beyond that it
has gone now to
surgical procedures
people of color are using
skin
whiteners
to
become white
and white people are going tanning until
they become
till they become super and there's
nothing wrong with tanning and getting
some you know healthy vitamin d but you
know what i'm talking about the ones
that end up looking like they're working
in the chimney
and jersey shore yeah
or some people are fixing their eyes
because they're confused they're
deviated from
from the path and with those deviations
it's not just theological
it also becomes
physical it becomes
mental
and we are trying to
stay and following that path and it is
like holding to the hot coal
it is
almost as hard everyone is against you
become a stranger
you talk about masculine prophets
you become a stranger
you
you talk about some of the things that
we're talking about you become a
stranger everyone thinks what are these
people saying i think i should turn it
off because it is uncomfortable it is a
very bitter pill to swallow that's why
we don't have that many people following
our content as opposed to others who are
talking
sorry but silly things garbage
you know rubbish rubbish as the british
say right
it's rubbish
they don't want to hear real problems
and then when you're talking about real
problems people say you're just negative
all the time we need to be positive and
so on
so
yes indeed we are trying to be positive
but we need to be realistic
so
going back to what i was saying
i think the prophet salallahu is the the
typical example if anyone wants to
understand masculinity in the most
authentic way
it is the prophet salallahu sallam
because indeed and we've had the
discussion
when you picked me up
there's
brothers who are desperately looking for
some guidance some masculinity their
fitra is resonating and there are some
people offering certain things out there
under different names and different
labels
and a lot of the muslim men are leaning
towards that because there's nothing
else out there
the ummah is not talking about these
things
however because those things are not
those labels or systems are not based on
the infallible
revelation from the creator of the
heavens and the earth
then they go
as i said it becomes super saturated
becomes too much
we have a question from brother anthony
uh gabriel he by the way he he reverted
about uh three three weeks ago
alhamdulillah
actually right so what would be a
solution to them not listening do you
think there could be a different
approach
masha'allah may allah bless brother
anthony and welcome to the dean minutes
it's the best thing you could have ever
done in your life man i remember
this room that i'm sitting in bro right
now
okay this is where my youtube channel
started bro in this room man
how many years ago did you reverb in
this room
well i started my youtube channel in
this room um
16 years ago almost
16 years ago exactly this room man
yep
and i had this cupboard at that time
yeah still oh yeah this is the room
and i reverted 19 years ago
alhamdulillah so i remember that day man
it's the best day man it's the best day
of my life man
you don't ever doubt don't have don't
ever doubt your choice bro it's not the
best choice you've ever made shaytan's
going to try to make you
doubt bro just
just punch him in the face bro with some
car bro boom just make dua
alhamdulillah
so answer your questions though brother
one more thing one more thing one more
thing guys stay tuned we're going to be
reacting to some of gabriel's old videos
where he looks like a soccer player
named romario very young
in sha allah i was i was watching some
of uh i think me and gabriel we prayed
uh i think it was
and then i literally whipped up my phone
bro and i was like bro look at this
video bro
and it's like from like 15 years ago bro
you know it's funny bro you know what's
funny bro i was
in this city okay i went to high school
here
not far from this place
and i was playing soccer
and my jersey was yellow and i have
number 11 bro
no joke
bro
this is otherwise the time of snowflake
sugar coating uh anthony don't worry we
didn't forget your question we're just
going to quickly go through these um
sister the hajj lover rights there's a
lack of reach out for the youth
sometimes they feel like they're being
judged i mean that's all i felt before
na hamdulillah a good relationship with
allah i came
this is surprisingly an emotional stream
lost some people in my life because i
said i do not support the alphabet
movement and the things i don't know or
the things is i don't know why they were
surprised i've never supported them
anyway publicly subhanallah
well let's see so here's the question
right i do think that
we need to
to do more work
systematically as opposed to just
directly
face people i mean you have to oppose
people sometimes
sometimes it can be
harder than others you have to be very
wise and how you do it that's to be a
strategy problem is right now we muslims
have no strategy in what we are doing
we're just doing things we're winging it
let's be honest we are winging it
even let's be honest bro like i mean
i don't know
a lot of the podcasts that you see out
there if you were to sit with someone
say okay so what's your strat where are
you trying to go
from here honestly what's your objective
okay i want to educate the people yeah
that's very generic
it's still very very generic when you
say i want to educate the people i want
to find this no
what is your
end goal what do you want to do with it
the reality is when we ask ourselves
that question myself you guys anyone
the truth is that
we are winging it
all right now when you look at others
who are opposing us they're not winging
it they have a 30-year plan at least
right but we're winging it
that's the problem so when you have a
strategy
when you have a strategy then you can
align yourself and choose
but not compromise you're not going to
compromise
you're going to work systematically
and you're going to try to make changes
system level
to be able to find effect because if i
just go face to face with someone
they're not going to
fully maybe they will alhamdulillah some
have
but most people becomes an issue of ego
if me and you go face to face it will
become an issue of ego that's real for
me and for you
let's be honest
and that's why most people a lot of
these debates
might not work
it can work for spectators
who are watching depending on who's
going to win like wow man that was great
debate i'm delighted islam because of
this okay it no doubt
no doubt sometimes there has to be that
muslim for example had to publicly show
that those wizards were wrong and that
they were just tricking people he
publicly specifically chose the time and
the location to expose them publicly
all right so that the spectators can see
the boy and the king
right bismillah
when he shot the arrow in the name of
the name of the boy
of the lord of this boy
why did he say that
he wanted to gather everyone so they can
witness that that's the only way
and he sacrificed himself
speaking of real masculinity sacrifice
man
right sacrifice who is willing to
sacrifice today everyone says ah but i
have a family man but i have a future
man
i i don't have to pay bills man that's
why you're never gonna be remembered
because you're never going to sacrifice
so your name is just gonna go six feet
under
no one will remember you like imam ahmed
for example rahim allah
as the last man standing
who doesn't compromise
so yeah we're winging it we need to have
a strategy we need to affect the systems
as well but yes
face to face as well no doubt but you
can just have one one is just going to
it might give you
results it might not it depends
it depends
bro let's see we got uh
brother shafiko writes on bengali and i
don't know if i can agree but it seems
like there is a lack of masculinity in
the bengali community
as in bengalis are more pacifistic
pacifistic than other cultures bro i'll
say this my personal experience with
bengalis is just this i'm not speaking
on behalf of every bengali right because
i don't want you know oh what about you
know there are still good bengalis
listen there's good people everywhere
what i've seen too much in the desi
culture in the south asian culture is
they care they care way too much about
what other people think
and i feel like that in and of itself is
a very feminine trait when you care too
much about what other people think and
you're worried about oh what's people
going to say you you're going to have a
long beard
you're praying five times a day people
are going to think this
who cares what people think right if
you're on the hook you're on the hook
that's what matters when the prophet saw
was sent when all the prophets
were sent they came at the time where
they had to oppose directly conflict
every status quo and norm of the society
at that time in the region that they
were sent
this is a very masculine thing to do we
shouldn't shy away from it we shouldn't
want to appease everyone as
said ya allah make us of the few right
yeah yeah and i think the i think the
main point is that no matter where you
go there's basically a lack of
masculinity
uh generally
uh i don't think honestly i personally
can't think of one place where i'm like
yeah you know what masculinity is
thriving there there are men there there
are you know actual like
there are like proper men there
i think it's just a worldwide thing
because of like colonialism and
orientalism just kind of spreading all
across the world
i i can say one thing
i can say that
in some of the countries where life is
hard there's still you find some like
for example like in gaza
masha'allah man you know
because
they're
they're pushed through it they have to
they have to
good times create a weak man isn't it
right that's saying it is what it is
people are enjoying having an easy life
bro i lost it bro
bro i don't know if anyone anyone
watching this was like into pokemon bro
just like me and angel bro but
i want to say something right now bro
brother or sister i mean
this is single-handedly in the year that
we've been on youtube this is the best
comment
in a live chat that we have ever gotten
bro so bad
what is that
that's that's that's a masculine train
right there
the the the warrior
even if he is hurt he doesn't give up
you know he's always gonna kick his man
yeah the warrior is never gonna back
down bro even if he's wounded even if
the warrior is wounded he still shows up
now he's still standing straight
yeah
i had a quick question bro so a lot of
people are misconstruing
cockiness with confidence right so
there's a there's a huge there's a lot
of movements right i'm not gonna name
any right now red pill purple pillow
there's too many pills about account now
but there's a lot of movements and they
advocate for men
almost being arrogant almost having this
type of like just ego you know just
narcissism
and we look at islam and you know we see
that the prophet very humble not weak
very humble
now a lot of men they can't draw the
line between
being
i guess humble and genuine and authentic
without being weak
and they can't draw the line between
being confident strong
as a motman but not being cocky and fake
right so what are your thoughts on this
bro
it is a very fine line
it is a very fine line
and if you don't have
the if you don't put allah first and
foremost
in every single equation in your life
whatever you do
you should always check your intention
your nia
something that the sahaba is too dull
and they're so worried about their
intention
but if you look at who they were
be it the battlefields just their daily
life
those are real men
however
however they're called monks at night
because of their prayer
they were
as described in some of the hadith that
their beards would be soaked with tears
which is a characteristic that
in general
the 21st century masculinity movement
denies that men should cry or that they
have emotions
that's something that we totally totally
disagree with with these movements
now there's you control yourself not
like
you know
there's this i think this video this
video of like
so
sorry
bro i wish i was i understood what the
joke was
sorry there's this video that
that it's i think it shows like 90s like
the guy
he bumps his
his
shoulder onto a door or something
and then like it goes to like 2 000.
like ow
in 2020
it's not good
mm-hmm you know i alright yeah i saw
that i thought there's a few of them
like that yeah
i can't i can't say more sorry
[Laughter]
bro i apologize
i thought you were fake crying
i thought i honestly thought you were a
fake crying uh to kind of imitate the
the soy boys that cry on camera and
stuff
but you kind of laughter bro
i love that
i love that
i do i do apologize i'm not trying to be
disrespectful but
uh forgive me please it's the real
estate in the dunya man come on it's
like 7 58 p.m right now hashtag gabriel
after dark if you made it this far
so you know alhamdulillah all right my
the next thing
on my mind um you know while gabriel
changes the blood this is the problem
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't know if anyone
watching this knows the inside joke i'm
not even going to say it if you know you
know if you saw the video you saw the
video insha allah dodged over lover
writes i feel left out subhanallah all
right
all right so
one thing on my mind is
you know
unless did you have more to answer that
question or was that it more or less
okay yeah so
we we are
it's it's a it's a phenomenon it's a
weakness it's a phenomenon
and um
there's just so many things that
contribute to that
and i believe that we need to
like the things that we're doing
to at least at least raise awareness i
believe we're just scrapping the surface
just raising awareness
and i pray that we're going to take it
to the next level with some more
projects i think i hope it goes beyond
this podcast i do believe that that is
important to keep in mind i am working
on some projects
already and i've been working on some
and inshallah we can share that
hopefully
in the future
so uh amin i want to give you a quick
shout out right now
you got the award for the best live chat
comment and the worst live chat comment
in the same stream i don't know how it's
possible subhanallah well we got two
super chats right now let's go through
them bismillah so the first one from
brother ismail um what are your guys
thoughts on alamkalam and using reason
logic and philosophy to explain islamic
concepts
gabriel
here we go
here we go
here we go boys
logic is a man-made science it has flaws
you have to really master it
to be able
to
use it
you have to be super super amazing at it
you have to be at the level of imam
razali and even he's been criticized
but he has responded to the philosophers
for example
you have to be at the level of sheikh
islam
who himself responded to the philosopher
using their principles
you have to be at the level of imam abu
hanifah who used to debate atheists
and philosophers
and destroyed them
not many people could master it to such
an extent
it is
a does it have something to do with the
fitra of course allah has given us
reason
and throughout the quran that is very
apparent
however looking at the islamic history
for the people who got involved in
there has been a lot of
problems
and that's why a lot of the scholars
were very careful and really really
cautioned people from getting into some
people got into that
because they had to
and others i think should just stay out
of it
i have not met people
who became more confused other than
those who have really gotten deep into
philosophy
all right
[Music]
so
in our context we are
are all just
a one we are all just regular folks
even if we studied islam
some more than the others in the end
none of us are scholars let us be very
very open about that
so
in our context i would say people should
like people talk about philosophy
to prove islam
i think we should stick to
basics of islam
to strengthen our deen
we should use those principles to maybe
strengthen our faith
and to make sense for ourselves
once you engage in a discussion with
someone else you don't know
what the other person has under their
belt and how they can respond to you
and that might confuse you and maybe
even cause you to leave islam i've seen
that many many many times
so
it depends
it depends but most of the scholars told
the regular people to stay away
from it this is my personal advice to my
dear brothers and sisters
to stick to the
basics of islam
and to stick to the
evidence that the quran provides
in the end if someone doesn't want to
believe you cannot guide them allah
tells us that already no matter how
smart you are and what kind of speech
you're going to give them
if allah doesn't wish to guide them he
will not
guide them so you just present and some
people have been guided just through a
few ayat of the quran
actually most people who have come to
islam have been guided to very very
basic things
really yeah
i i can count the amount of people that
have really gone at the deep
philosophical level and then they said
yeah man i was convinced
right
so
let's stick for us anyway for us who are
not scholars and just regular folks let
us stick to the
the basics inshallah
to the appear to the apparent things
like if you look around in the world
and i think that is very reasonable to
say
that if you look around the world and
you just think of this as allah says do
you think that this was created
just for just or this is it just
happened
indeed i think this is one of the
greatest philosophical questions
that any person
can ask themselves yeah what's the
purpose of this life can this be just
out of nothing it just happened
and you will definitely when you look
around in nature and as allah says in
is
so the people ponder in the creation
heavens and the earth
the rev the the the creation of the
heavens and the changing of the day and
the night
[Music]
they say that there is these are aya
these are evidence
those who ponder
allah
standing sitting laying on their side
and all kinds of statuses right so when
you stand is different when you sit is
different when you lay on your side
you're about to sleep your brain waves
are different
there's different status states
and then they ponder the creation around
the earth
then they cut they realize they deduce
they conclude
or a lord you did not create this in
vain it doesn't happen in vain they
didn't just happen
praise be to you save us from the
punishment of that part i think i think
it's a very philosophical thing but it's
a very
basic thing
as well that any person they're sincere
sincere not arrogant and they just look
at a tree or they look at snow speaking
of snowflakes real snowflakes
how different they are
i mean the design it's impossible for
someone to say yeah i think this just
happened impossible it's impossible i'm
sorry it's just humanly rationally even
philosophically logically impossible
whatever you want to call it yeah but
it's simple
100 and if i can jump in quickly i
actually i want to agree with that
because um subhanallah if you look at
all of the sahaba radhillahu
they've all basically all of them
accepted just because of uh the ayat
allah was sending down the prophet the
prophet allah said on his character and
some you know what he brought and you
know all of that and it had very little
to do with
uh you know kind of logical arguments
because
they they all basically believe in allah
to begin with they just had to remove
the idols there were actually people
called like i think we call them like
the timers the people who believe that
that time is the only thing that is true
that time you know running out is what
makes them and kills them and so on and
so forth so they're kind of like
atheists in a way
or
people just believe the universe is you
know all there is and allah revealed
the quran you know
do they believe they were created from
nothing or were they themselves the
creator of themselves and
i'm not going to say this is an argument
that allah makes but he just speaks the
truth he asks this kind of rhetorical
question
basically giving three things that are
impossible
either they were created from nothing
it's a contradiction
um or they you know did they create
themselves another contradiction or were
they themselves the creator of like the
heavens of the earth and all that stuff
it's all contradictions you basically
end up with god i think it's not
actually no i i know islam in and of
itself is enough because you don't
necessarily have to prove god if you
prove islam that's enough
that's do you prove god as well so i
don't think you always need to take that
route but it does help 100
in some cases it but i do understand it
can get tricky if you look at the like
mutasira for example and i'm not going
to go into details because you know even
this telling the story might confuse
people uh but
basically with the whole you know uh
quran created not created kind of thing
it was actually a christian bishop who
went to
um maybe one of the governors
of allah and he made this argument this
logical argument
when greek philosophy was kind of making
its way into the ummah at the time and
because of this logical argument
uh it really stumped the muttazira so
they just kind of
conceded and said okay you know the
quran is created and they actually made
it like basically
obligatory for all the to give that
fatwa and to say the quran is created
and to not disagree and
brother gabriel he mentioned um
what's it called he mentioned the uh
imam muhammad bin laden allah he was the
only man that refused the only sheikh
that refused the only man actually that
refused as far as i know
and i know that gabriel is frozen
unfortunately i hope you can at least
hear this inshallah
but the only man that refused imam um
ahmad bin rahim allah
he was asking where is it in the quran
where is the quran you say there's no
words in the quran how do you know this
why do you say this and so on and so
forth so that kind of you know our
argument wasn't enough and he didn't
combat it logically either
man
why don't you uh continue reading some
of these uh these messages inshaallah
bro you got that mashallah voice and
broadcaster voice inshallah
let you go
gabriel can't stop laughing i need the
link to the video now
i i do i do apologize i apologize
nothing to apologize for man you're
laughing shotless
says finally channel like a month ago
masha'allah i love your content guys
brother gabriel is based and uh might i
suggest you events for a future guest
insha allah that would honestly be
amazing i love that brother
inshallah
thoughts on minor signs supposedly
ending soon only allah knows when the
hour is coming but
i would love to hear your input on it
gabriel any thoughts on that what do you
think
this is something that yeah the science
of eschatology and the time of the hour
is again something that we need to be
careful with
and only because only allah knows when
the hour is
the signs are only meant as a warning
for us to
repent and to be careful
as not to guess when the hour is coming
so i will leave it at that
inshallah inshallah
i mean it's it's oh well let me read the
question first how do we reconcile that
with verses of the quran asking us to
reason and use our logic unless i must
understand this verse so you did not
misunderstand the verses i think you
misunderstood what brother gabriel was
saying and what i added on later we're
not saying don't use logic don't use
rationality don't use your your um your
you know reasoning your logic your mind
we're not saying don't use that no one's
saying that we're just saying that when
it comes to greek
logic and philosophy it it can become
confusing because there's something
called logical fallacies right i'll just
explain it like this this is just me
myself talking there are logical
fallacies where people say things that
seem logical
but they're actually illogical they
don't make sense they can't can you give
an example bro yeah so one example is
one example is you know when it rains
the ground is wet right and if someone
comes and says therefore every time the
ground is wet it rained well that's a
fallacy because what if someone just
pulled out a hose and made the ground
wet you know what if a car or a truck
carrying water passed by and water
spilled out on the floor it doesn't
necessitate that it actually rained and
there is like probably bro maybe
dozens of logical fallacies people can
use straw man's um cordless and
causation this is what i mentioned all
these different fallacies that you know
when i say them you probably don't even
know what the heck they mean because
they're not common knowledge so when
someone comes and they make an argument
like
i think maybe it's good if i mention the
muthazilla argument because it'll make
sense here and i'll explain why it
doesn't make sense so
basically in the time of the muthazilla
a christian bishop went to them and they
said basically is jesus the word of god
and they're like yeah and they're like
was he created they're like yeah he
created jesus jesus was created by god
and he's a word of god
because that's what the quran says
and
and then they ask is the quran the word
of god and they say yeah and they're
like well was the quran created he's
like oh
dang
but what's the fallacy the the logical
fallacy is called the fallacy of
equivocation when you take a word that
has two different meanings and you give
the wrong meaning for example if i
you know i like things run on
electricity right so if i if i shock
myself am i gonna run really fast it's a
fallacy it doesn't make sense so in this
case the term kalimatullah the word of
allah that's where they made the mistake
because it can mean speech it can mean
speech that you write down like allah he
says in the quran if the ocean were ink
for writing the oceans would be
exhausted before the kalimatullah before
the words of allah and but in another
ayah in the quran allah says the
likeness of jesus is similar to that of
adam because they were both created by
the kalim of allah the word of god allah
said be and he was and in that case we
know that's exactly what happened with
isaiah here's the word of god because
allah said be and he was so that was a
fallacy that they committed but my point
was that imam
allah he didn't respond like that he
didn't respond by giving oh you know you
use this logical fallacy and
you know he responded he's asking where
is that in the quran where is that in
the quran where did you get this from
show me where it is in the quran and
that's that was his position and
i wish my neck was as long as a draft so
he can
raise the word before he alter
so he can't wrongful wrongfully say
something to displease allah
i don't know i have a hard time
understanding me too bro
inshallah all right next
uh i was so lost and i wasn't practicing
but one day i decided to
meditate and it was a vicar video and
when i said subhanallah i cried like a
baby and have been practicing since then
you feel it just me subhanallah that
if you don't mind if you're following us
on instagram send us that video i'd love
to personally watch it myself
um and definitely go over it maybe you
know consult a scholar too and then
maybe even post it on our channel as a
community post insha allah but please
send us our video
instagram the three muslims one word
insha allah
that should be it for all the questions
alhamdulillah
are there any closing remarks that you
want to leave people with just to ponder
on things um you know as we understand
yeah
okay so i mean i know we kind of
deviated from the main topic a little
bit we are experts at that i'm an expert
at that anyway
but i think we made some good points
today tonight
however going back to the topic of the
masculine prophets and masculinity i
want to
re
state
redefine say again the definition of
masculinity
right it is the fitra
of the male
the fitra of the male of the male
gender that is
fine-tuned by the revelation
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that has
all those characteristics that we
mentioned akida
knowledge bravery
being resilient
and so on as strength body strength
mental strength courage we've talked
about all these things
and for anyone who wants to understand
more
like we really really need to get back
to that
when you contextualize things that's
when things become more clear
so go back to the seerah
read
like one of the best advice people ask
me
how do i fix myself
read the quran and ponder over it
go back to the seerah to understand the
context
we connect we connect you why do people
watch tick tock and instagram social
media because they can connect to people
they get inspired
problem is we muslims don't really
create that good content these days that
can really inspire i think you and i
talked about right those high quality
productions can you really compete with
what the others are putting out there
no not really
so
the best thing we have right now is
books for now so go back to the books
visualize some of the things that are
said there some of the stories
the lessons
and try to connect to those then you
will understand real masculinity
inshallah without
any doubt inshallah
inshallah
um you guys look forward to in the next
few weeks no promises but if we can
coordinate something
me gabriel and rami i'm gonna do a meet
up so inshallah a quick little video in
the in person
um aside from that guys keep us in your
duas
first and foremost if you like our
content consider becoming a patron or
youtube member support the dawah and
support gabriel's channel too if you
cannot do that your duas are all we ask
it is enough it is sufficient
and may allah bless you
for making dua for us and watching our
content in sha allah
i mean
for tuning in to the readers podcast in
the dunya
foreign